the Senate unanimously passes a massive
government spending plan 3.3 million
Americans are now out of work and
coronavirus begins to hit New York City
hospitals I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn you have a right
to privacy so protect it at expressvpn
comm slash Ben now more than ever check
out expressvpn comm slash Ben alrighty
so let's go right into the latest
updates we now know that some 3.3
million Americans are out of work as of
like this week the jobless claims have
shot up massively this week according to
CNBC Americans displaced by coronavirus
crisis filed unemployment claims in
record numbers last week the Labor
Department reported Thursday a surge to
3.28 million that is an increase about
three million people in the course of
one week alone one week alone the number
shatters the Great Recession peak of
665,000 in March 2009 and the all-time
mark of 695 thousand in October 1982 the
previous week was 280 mm so we shot up
three million lost jobs in one week so
when people tell you don't worry about
the economy this is all about saving
lives just understand the economy has
some pretty real ramifications for the 3
million people who just lost their jobs
no doubt most of those people hourly
workers or blue-collar workers or people
who are not making 150 thousand dollars
a year consensus estimates from
economists survey by Dow Jones showed an
expectation for 1.5 million in new
claims but individual forecasts on Wall
Street had been anticipating a much
higher number surge comes amid a
crippling slowdown brought on by the
corona virus crisis well to be fair that
has not brought on just by consumer
activity that is brought on by state and
federal governments and international
governments everywhere telling people
that they must stay in their homes it
turns out that it's hard to shop and it
makes you a little bit leery about
spending your money when you're not sure
if you're gonna have a job in five
minutes and also when you cannot go
outside turns out that really cuts down
on the capacity of the economy to keep
moving the 4 week moving average was
which smoothes out weekly distortions
was 1.7 million an increase of 27,500
from the previous week's revised average
the major stock indices it did open
higher wiping out sharp earlier losses
and that is because everybody sort of
expected this is coming this is already
priced and everybody knew that
you shut down the economy forcibly from
the outside the way this has happened
that that means that there's going to be
a major spike in unemployment that is
why the Senate voted 96 nothing
yesterday for the largest spending bill
in the history of the United States to
determine whether this sort of
government shutdown of all human
activity was necessary one of the things
that we're gonna have to look at is the
international scene we're going to have
to at some point here make and it makes
a big difference to to how the United
States reacts from here on in what is
the plan for reopening the economy what
is the plan for getting back to some
semblance of normalcy was it the right
move to shut down the schools was it the
right move to shut down all businesses
what was all of this the right move now
based on available information the
answer seems to be yes because you don't
want to turn into Italy but what if it
turns out that Italy is the outlier and
for example the UK is much more close to
the norm what if it turns out that South
Korea is a little closer to the norm in
Spain as closer to the outlier we don't
know the answers to these questions so
in a second we're gonna look at some of
the International stories and where this
thing is going because this thing is
slowing down in Italy now it is possible
to say both yes you needed the hard stop
because Italy required everybody to lock
down for like three weeks in order to
start seeing a day on teh decline in new
cases it is also possible to say that
maybe we should have taken the Swedish
approach Sweden didn't shut down its
economy nearly at all we're gonna get to
this in just one second first let's talk
about how HR issues can kill you it no
matter whether your business is up or
down the last thing you need is an HR
issue and HR has become even more of a
nightmare now with the thickets of
legislation and regulations that have
now been passed regarding what you can
and cannot do with your employees when
you are running a business HR issues can
cost you a ton of money and right now
you don't have the money lying around to
go hire an HR specialist at 75 thousand
a hundred thousand dollars a year if
you're running a business what you need
is an HR manager that is dedicated to
you but at a very very low cost and this
is where Bambi comes in be a MBE created
specifically for small business you get
a dedicated HR manager you can craft a
HR policy maintain your compliance all
for 99 bucks a month which is a great
price to pay very very very low and
inexpensive to make sure that your
business is not hit with waves of hun
waves of government liability your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email real-time chat from unborn
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day to day all
for just 99 bucks a month month month no
hidden fee
you can cancel anytime let Bambi help
you out get your free HR audit today go
to Bambi comm slash Shapiro right now to
schedule your free HR audit that is BA
mba.com slash capiro bam - the BAE comm
slash up here I'll go check them out
right now for that free HR on it cuz you
can't afford HR issues right now you
just can't go to Bambi comm slash up
here oh okay so where do we stand right
now domestically and internationally
well domestically we are all worried
we're about to become Italy Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti warned of mass death
and condemned false hope presumably that
false hope coming from President Trump
on Wednesday he told LA residents that
they will be confined to their homes
until at least May okay it is now
last I checked March 26th so that means
another month of people being confined
to their homes
Garcetti said I think this is at least
two months be prepared for even longer
Garcetti pushed back against what he
called premature optimism in the face of
kovat 19 saying that leaders who suggest
were on the verge of business as usual
are putting lives at risk he says I
can't say that strongly enough he says
giving people false hope will crush
their spirits will kill more people
because it'll install it will instill a
sense of normal T and people will start
going back out and associating with one
another and then coronavirus will spike
again he says this will not kill most of
us who will kill a lot more people than
were used to dying around us our said he
said the city was anywhere from six to
twelve days away from the fate of New
York City where a surgeon patients with
coronavirus is threatening to overwhelm
the health system as of noon on Tuesday
LA County Public Health officials said
that there were 662 confirmed cases of
kovat 19 with eleven confirmed deaths
the actual numbers are no doubt higher
with officials only recently beginning
to roll out testing now those numbers
are higher on both ends meaning it is
way higher than 662 people in all of LA
County who have Kovan 19 and probably
there are more people who have died of
it but just haven't been identified as
victims of Kovan 19 because we weren't
really testing for it now the the bottom
number that that that denominator is
significantly larger than the numerator
meaning that the death rate on
coronavirus I mentioned yesterday is
likely in order of magnitude lower than
what the w-h-o is saying the death rate
is mainly because there are tons of
silent cases running around people who
have not even experienced symptoms and
who have coronavirus and are passing it
on to others with that said if this
thing is super SuperDuper transmissible
you can still swamp emergency rooms you
can still swamp ventilators and icy use
if there are just tons of people who end
up with it
right if the wrong number is very large
even if the rate is very small the ICUs
are not based on percentages the ICUs
are based on the broad number of beds
available the ventilators are based on
the raw number of ventilators available
Garcetti says the main horrifying thing
I keep thinking about and every local
leader is is being kept awake is the
projection of how many people will get
this the projection of what the
mortality rate will be how many dead
we'll have well we have hundreds of
thousands or tens of thousands that's
what keeps us up okay so in New York
City there are already articles about
apocalyptic surges at a New York City
Hospital and it's important to sort of
parse what here is apocalyptic and and
what is not so obviously we are going to
see hospitals that are crushed under the
weight of this thing we're obviously
gonna see overcrowding so far the ICUs
have not been overcrowded what I mean by
that is that they will be I mean there's
very little doubt that over the next
week two weeks that there will be more
people who need ICU beds than ICU beds
available there will be more people who
need ventilators and ventilators
available although there's some new
breakthroughs in terms of ventilator
technology that have been put out there
and that are pretty fascinating and and
could actually ratchet up the number of
ventilators available in fairly short
order which would be supremely important
obviously but with that said the the the
crisis right now that you're seeing in
the New York Times is them saying
there's not enough morgue space okay not
enough space is a bad thing but
you can make more expertise aliy and
everybody sort of acknowledges that that
just requires a federal go ahead the
morgue space is not the big issue here
because those people not to be course
about this but those people are already
dead I mean that what what you really
need are the resources to keep the
people who are alive alive and so the
question is when do we hit that point we
were already hearing that by Tuesday the
system was gonna be overwhelmed remember
Andrew Cuomo said that he said that by
earlier this week the system was already
going to be overwhelmed that doesn't
mean the system won't be overwhelmed it
doesn't mean that the system won't be
put you know basically
pedal-to-the-metal but it does mean that
it has not quite yet done this right and
Andrew Cuomo is is even admitting as
much right Andrew Cuomo says that they
have in fact dramatically slowed the
rate of increase already and this thing
has only been locked down for like a
week and a half right here's Andrew
Cuomo suggesting that the rate of
increase in New York City has been
decreased fairly dramatically
Westchester we have dramatically slowed
what was an exponential increase
so again on the good news side can you
slow the rate of infection yes how do
you know look at what we did in
Westchester that was the hottest cluster
in the United States of America we
closed the schools we closed gatherings
we brought in testing and we have
dramatically slowed the increase hey
Bill DeBlasio the awful mayor of New
York he says half of New Yorkers will be
infected but the question isn't how many
people will be infected you have to
assume tons and tons of people will be
or already have been infected with
coronavirus the real question is over
what period of time and do we have the
medical resources necessary to deal with
those people
here's idiot communist mayor of New York
Bill DeBlasio who is going to the gym
five minutes ago while telling everybody
else they couldn't go to the gym five
minutes ago groundhog killer bill de
blasio probably more than half of all
New Yorkers will be infected with this
disease thank God for the vast majority
it will be a very limited mild
experience but for a lot of other people
it's gonna be really tough and we're
gonna lose some people and our job is to
make sure that we save every single New
Yorker we can okay so that amounts to
slowing the transmissions as as Cuomo is
talking about and it amounts to
ratcheting up the number of ICU beds and
ventilators available it'll be really
interesting to see from a social science
perspective and from a data perspective
is in the end how many ICU beds do we
end up needing how wrong are the models
are how right are the models in a second
we're going to examine the possibility
that some of these models are supremely
wrong about the number of people who are
gonna end up needing ICU beds I have an
example from the UK I mean this is
optimistic and maybe not maybe maybe
this is totally wrong maybe we do get
hit like Italy gets it but maybe not I'm
gonna bring you some news about that in
just one second courtesy of our friends
in the United Kingdom first let us talk
about a simple fact you're at home right
now you still need to send a mail out
you still need to send out packages
you're still running a business and you
need your business ready to go as soon
as things reopen anyway and this is why
you need stamps.com we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now what if
you need to go to the post office good
news you don't have to go to the post
office my friends at stamps calm are
here to help you out anything you can do
at the post office you can do at stamps
calm except stand and crowded lines
print posted
on demand skip those crowded lines at
the post office plus you can actually
save some serious money with discounts
you can't even get at the post office in
the first place
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you are hunkering down right now
whether you're a small business selling
is sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products or you're just
working from home and you need to mail
stuff stamps.com can handle all of this
with ease with stamps that coming at
great discounts as well five cents off
every first-class stamp up to 40% off US
Postal Service shipping rates which is a
major savings plus right now
stamps.com is offering UPS services with
discounts up to 62 percent so it is even
cheaper than ever for e to use USPS
services and I'd have to go to the post
office with stamps comm right now my
listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitments just go to stamms com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
comm enter Shapiro again stamps.com
and enter Shapiro at the top of the home
page make sure to get that four-week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitment okay so as
I say in New York City right now there's
a lot of talk about the hospitals being
full they're getting close to full but
they have not been overwhelmed as of yet
and we were told they were gonna be
overwhelmed earlier this week again this
does not mean that they're not gonna be
overwhelmed in the next week and a half
it does mean that we are ramping up
supplies we are ramping up ventilators
we are ramping up ICU beds so according
to the New York Times which is already
you know pulling the trigger on
everything is apocalyptic and say 13
deaths in a day an apocalyptic
coronavirus surge at a New York City
Hospital okay first of all let's let's
just point out lots of people buy at
hospitals lots and lots of people buy at
hospitals that does not mean a surge
didn't happen at this hospital it does
mean that 13 deaths in a day at a
hospital is actually not a supremely
large number what you're where you start
to pull it pull the parachute where you
start to pull the panic button and hit
the panic button is when you're saying
50 60 deaths a day from one source at a
hospital in several hours on Tuesday dr.
Ashley Bray performed chest compressions
in Elmhurst Hospital Center on a woman
in her 80s a man in his 60s and a 38
year old who reminded the doctor of her
fiance all had tested positive for
coronavirus and had gone into cardiac
arrest arrest all eventually died
Elmhurst is a 545 bad public hospital in
Queens has begun transferring patients
not suffering from coronavirus to other
hospitals as it moves toward becoming
dedicated entirely to the outbreak and
this is what you would expect
right outlying hospitals are now being
inundated with patients who do not have
coronavirus so we can shift resources to
urban centers or coronaviruses likely to
hit the hardest which makes perfect
sense right this is what Italy did not
do Italy got overwhelmed because Italy
did not have the capacity to bring other
patients from northern Italy to other
areas of Italy and this ended up with
massive levels of overwhelm in the
system this is why if you go to southern
Italy the death rates from coronavirus
are nowhere near the death rates from
coronavirus and northern Italy why
they're part of the same country
presumably tons of people are still
getting coronavirus in southern Italy
and in Rome well perhaps the reason is
because the medical system in northern
Italy was not prepared for this and they
could not shift resources fast enough
also worth noting by the way Italy is a
unique country and that a huge
percentage of people who live in Italy
live with their parents and that makes
an enormous difference in terms of
transmission rates in fact if you look
at the countries that are being hardest
hit right now
the share of the population aged 30 to
49 living with their parents Italy it's
23% in the u.s. it is 6.4 percent which
is closer to Germany or the UK which
means that infections of the elderly are
going to be less prevalent in places
like UK Germany and the u.s. Sweden
France write that the prevalence of
elderly people getting this thing gonna
be a lot lower than in Italy where
pretty much 1 in 5 people aged 30 to 49
lives with their parents
meanwhile the the New York Times
continues a refrigerated truck has been
stationed outside to hold the bodies of
the dead over the past 24 hours New York
City's public hospital system said in a
statement 13 people at Elmhurst had died
its apocalypta detective said dr. Bray
27 in general Meza general medicine
resident at the hospital across the city
hospitals are beginning to confront the
kind of heroine surgeon cases that has
overwhelmed other healthcare systems in
China Italy and other countries okay
they're confronting it but does that
mean that they are overwhelmed yet not
necessarily right Cuomo said that that
social distancing that has been
effective in tamping down the growth he
said that it's almost too good to be
true he said this week the state's
hospitalization estimations were down
markedly from a doubling of cases every
two days to every four days which is a
dramatic slowing hospitals are under
siege says the new york times new york
city's hospitals run the gamut from
prestigious teaching institutions
catering to the elite to public
hospitals providing care for some of the
poorest communities in the nation
regardless of whom they serve if you
have been spared the impact of the
pandemic a flood of sick and fearful
knee
has besieged emergency rooms across the
city but again nowhere in this article
does it say that the system has yet been
overwhelmed now again I keep saying this
it could be right we could see it
overwhelmed all of them more than 1800
into ICU beds in the city are expected
to be full by Friday according to a FEMA
briefing obtained by the New York Times
and patients could stay there for weeks
limiting space for newly sick in people
but every day we buy in order to create
more ICUs in order to create more
ventilators it's a day that unless
people are going to die because again
until those beds are full and we have
overwhelm like in Italy you're not going
to see the sorts of mass death you see
in Italy almost had he hoped that
officials could quickly add units by
dipping into a growing supply of
ventilators the federal government is
sending a 1000 bed hospital ship to New
York it's not scheduled to arrive until
mid-april officials have begun directing
for 250 bed hospitals at the Javits
Convention Center in midtown Manhattan
that could be ready in a week also
officials are discussing converting
hotels and arenas into temporary medical
centers now again talking about how they
are filling up morgues that's not the
that's not the end of the world buried
deep in this article talking about the
apocalypse is a spokeswoman for the
city's office saying quote we have
significant more capacity in our five
citywide sites and the ability to expand
so the the notion that everybody has
been completely overwhelmed at this
point and that people are dying in the
waiting room in the same way that has
been happening in Italy so far not true
so far that is not true
so again could be true but we're buying
time right now now why does this make me
a little bit more optimistic well
because there's a report out of the UK
according to new scientists calm the UK
according to the experts now has enough
ICU units for coronavirus patients so
one week ago they were saying that UK
was gonna get hit with like 230,000
deaths that the UK was gonna get
completely overwhelmed that the system
was gonna be completely overloaded and
lo and behold a week later they're like
oh no actually we have enough ICU beds
Neil Ferguson at Imperial College London
that is the source of the study by the
way that suggested the 2.2 million
people would die if there was no social
distancing in the United States he gave
evidence today into the UK parliamentary
the Select Committee on Science and
Technology
he said that expected increases in NHS
capacity and ongoing restrictions to
people's movements make him reasonably
confident the Health Service can cope
when the predicted peak of the up
demikhov's in two or three weeks UK
deaths from the disease are now unlikely
to exceed 20,000 he said and could in
fact be much lower well that's only an
order of magnitude off from what the
Imperial College study originally
suggested now it is easy to say okay
that social distancing it's shutting
down the economy but if that is the case
and that's gonna bear some serious
questions as to whether you actually
needed to have this complete shutdown in
the same way or alternatively how soon
we can get out from a complete shutdown
because here's the reality right Sweden
didn't do any of this stuff and Sweden
is not experiencing the same sort of
overwhelm that Italy is it turns out
that different countries are different
by the way even in Italy this is a good
piece of news even in Italy while the
deaths continue to be extremely high
like 683 new deaths in Italy yesterday
the spread does keep slowing day on day
this has been happening for about four
or five days for the fourth day in a row
the the total number of cases in the
country was rising at a slower pace than
usual
what you look at that this is the
flattening of the curve beginning to
actually happen in Italy which is the
country hardest hit by all of this and
by a large margin the country where most
people have died
confirmed contagions rose by six percent
from Tuesday to read fifty seven
thousand five hundred twenty one in
Italy the total number of recovered
patients is already over at nine
thousand in Italy care gonna get to
Sweden in just one second because again
we need comps we need to compare where
is the United States on these various
curves what measures are we taking in
were we going to be Italy or were we
always going to be closer to the UK or
France or Germany or Sweden they're very
different there are lots of different
variations in the treatment and in the
transmission because people associate
differently in different countries right
Italy's been particularly hard-hit
Spain is being hard-hit also their
medical systems nationalized healthcare
systems by the way not very good really
not very good they've got some serious
problems over there we'll get some more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that right now
you're stuck at home but you got a
broken car you can't go out to the auto
parts shop because that's not an
essential business so what do you need
you need Rock auto calm first of all you
should be using rockauto.com anyway
they've got a better selection than your
local auto parts store also they're not
gonna be up charging you if you are some
sort of experts as opposed to if you are
novice also they're going to ship it
directly to your house so why exactly
would you not use rockauto.com their
catalog is unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps of motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need and a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like the
airline's do so why would you spend up
to twice as much for the same parts that
would be illogical spock rockauto.com is
a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to Rock
Auto calm right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
Rock auto calm right shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you so as i say good
piece of news from UK they're not gonna
get overwhelmed they're now saying
Imperial college right that was the
source of the study that said hundreds
of thousands would die is now saying
under 20,000 people will probably die in
Great Britain which is in fact a flu
season
ok now that does not mean this was like
the flu okay we shut down the way we
never have for the flu and we're gonna
get flu like numbers anyway but it is
indicative of the fact that some of the
rates the death rates that were
originally put out that were just not
true and it is indicative of the fact
that a full-throated public debate is
gonna need to be had in the future about
how we deal with this kind of stuff
without completely shutting down the
world economy because look at Sweden
okay according to financial times Sweden
has to become an international outlier
in its response to the deadly
coronavirus outbreak that kept their
schools open they adopted few other
restrictions the Scandinavian nation has
been embarking on what one health expert
called a huge experiment this is
according again to the Financial Times
since the UK went into lockdown and
Monday evening Sweden is now the largest
European country with the fewest limits
limits on where people can go and what
they can do by the way remember the UK
only went on full lockdown like this
week and they're already saying that in
order of magnitude less people are going
to die than they predicted in that
imperial college study schools for
children up to age of 16 remain open
many people continue to go to work
packed commuter trains and buses were
reported this week in the capital of
Stockholm Sweden stands out at the
moment said Carl Bildt the former Prime
Minister Swedish authorities have been
gathering more than 500 people they
closed universities in higher education
colleges they or they advised workers to
stay home if possible authorities on
Tuesday ordered restaurants and bars
only to serve people at tables rather
than at the bar said they could create
some sort of social distancing vocal
media have been full of stories of
thousands of people gathering at Swedish
ski resorts which until Saturday were
completely open the virus has been
spreading
easily in mountain resorts in Austria
and Italy as well
Johan Carlson the head of Sweden's
public health agency last week defended
Sweden's approach said the country quote
cannot take draconian measures that have
a limited impact on the epidemic but
knock out the functions in society so
presumably the Democrats would accuse
the Swedish Health Minister of favouring
dollars over human lives because this is
the stupid political game we play in the
United States where we pretend that
public policy is not about balancing
risks and rewards it's all about if you
can save one life which by the way is
the last refuge of the political
scoundrel if you can just save one life
and before you say how about you you're
anti-abortion that's not about saving
one life that's about the deliberate
killing of a human being that's not
quite the same thing as deciding a
public policy risks and rewards Carlson
conceded the ninety thousand figure for
the number of people who die annually in
Sweden would increase significantly if
the health care system became
overburdened but there have been just
over two thousand reported kovat 19
cases in Sweden and 33 deaths compared
to 6,000 deaths in Italy Europe's worst
affected country Sweden's state
epidemiologist he said the future still
looks manageable he argued school should
stay open because otherwise you have
kids who transmit the disease or Homa
parents and grandparents which by the
way is 100% true a number of Swedish
health experts disagree it's always
easier to say that everything should be
shut down and then certain things should
remain open so Sweden's gonna be a
fascinating case study if it turns out
that Sweden is less hard-hit and a bunch
of countries that have been issuing
nationwide lock downs it's one thing to
do this in Italy where the things
already hit right it's another thing to
do this preemptively in the UK and then
four days later you're saying by the way
we do have enough ICU beds and we have
an offensive waiters I mean that unless
they dramatically secretly ramped up ICU
beds and ventilators that means that the
original estimates were quite wrong and
again none of this is to argue that in
the United States we don't need a full
stop given what we knew about the
epidemic when we knew about the epidemic
it does mean that all of these estimates
that were going to have to keep the
economy completely shuttered until June
or July are kind of crazy yeah they're
kind of crazy based on what we currently
know now again all of that could change
this is incredibly fluid we could see
the system begin to be overwhelmed I
keep hedging my bets here because I am
Not Afraid of saying the three words
that apparently every other person on
the subject is afraid of saying I don't
know you don't know nobody knows so I'm
giving you a wide variety of data so
that you can make the best available
judgment about what's happening one of
the things that has happened here is
that we started off with the possibility
of
stream economic loss balanced against
the possibility of extreme loss of life
right that was the initial assessment
and we said okay the possibility of
extreme economic loss takes a backseat
to the possibility of extreme loss of
human life totally on board with that
what happens when it's the possibility
of extreme loss of human life and that's
diminishing because as we get more data
in it looks a little better than we
thought it was going to we were bending
the curve in New York we're bending the
curve in Washington State and that
possibility of extreme economic loss is
no longer a possibility it is a hard
reality with millions of people losing
their jobs now if your talk about a 100%
possibility of a Great Depression for
the United States economically versus a
10% possibility of a pandemic that was
in line with any of the original
estimates and what points you start to
say ok we may need to tailor our
policies a little bit differently right
what is it 1% possibility is it 0%
possibility and what if the best
available estimates at this point are in
fact an order of magnitude lower than
they were even a week or two ago when
data were still coming in when it looked
like Italy could not flatten its curve
when it looked like the UK might be hit
with hundreds of thousands of deaths
what if it turns out that in the United
States what we're talking about is not a
million point one deaths as some
epidemiologists were originally
suggesting I thought that was way
overblown immediately but let's say it's
not 1 point 1 million deaths let's say
the what we're actually talking about in
the United States is something like
Great Britain meaning that we're talking
fifty to a hundred thousand deaths
okay now that's a horrible horrible
number it also happens to be that you're
talking about the loss of millions upon
millions of jobs and that does have a
pretty significant impact on people's
lives you're talking about the complete
shutdown of the world economy and to
pretend that that is not a counterweight
is silly also you have to determine
whether the difference that you are
talking about making and completely
shutting down society makes the
difference between say 50,000 deaths and
500,000 deaths or whether you're talking
about the difference between 50,000
deaths and 70,000 deaths
I know it's forbidden to talk about this
stuff it really you're not allowed to
talk about this stuff every public
policy decision comes down to talking
about this stuff I'm not saying I have
an answer I am saying that you're not
asking the questions and if our public
policymakers are not asking the
questions they are not doing their job
this is literally their job their job is
to determine what the various costs and
benefits of various public policies we
do it every single day and to not do it
in the midst of one a global pens out
and to the greatest economic shutdown in
the history of mankind okay that's what
this is right now the greatest economic
shutdown in the history of mankind that
would be absolutely foolish and I don't
care what quarter it sort of bumper
sticker slogan earing you suggest you
know the the we can't even ask these
questions because now you're taking
human life lightly I'm absolutely not
taking human life lightly I'm also not
taking anybody's economic livelihood
lightly I'm gonna taking people's jobs
lightly we have to take all of this
seriously and if you're not taking one
aspect of the seriously it's because
you're not a serious person sorry you're
not if you just say okay everything is
justified in order to stop the number of
deaths from being 50,000 plus one versus
just 50,000 that's because you're not a
serious person you're not okay be
because maybe the cost is worth it and
maybe the cost is not we make those
decisions every single day in American
public policy we do it meanwhile as I
say Washington State case growth has
declined we are seeing the Italian curve
being flattened and fairly dramatically
by the way it's been declining fairly
steadily in terms of the rate of growth
for days on end for actually weeks now
and it's been some up and down so the
trend line is is fairly clear at this
point we'll get to more of this in just
one site we'll talk about the economic
impact which of course has been
absolutely dramatic on American society
the sir as I say the certainty of
economic loss is very real now now the
possibility of the loss of American life
is still uncertain we don't know what
the percentages are and no one
apparently in the public health world is
being honest about their assessments
they won't give us like any numbers on
what percentage chance do you think it
is that it's actually a 500,000 versus
what percentage chance that it's 20,000
what like where's the sliding scale here
without that data it's very difficult to
argue for a reopening but maybe that's
the whole point we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about how you can save money at this
time very easily by shopping online I'm
talking about using honey okay honey is
a fantastic fantastic tool honey is the
free online shopping tool that saves you
money online
honey automatically finds the best promo
codes and then applies them to your cart
that makes online shopping finally feel
as easy as it's supposed to be imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites your target or Sephora's or Macy's
or eBay and suddenly there's a little
window that pops up and it says by the
way we've got a coupon code
this is exactly how honey works and you
save the money immediately and the
prices drop
I've saved tons of money using honey
it works on Amazon it works on eBay it
saves me money nearly every time I shop
online and right now basically that's
all we are doing honey has found it's
over 18 million members over two billion
dollars in savings which right now you
want to save some money sounds pretty
good to me
check out honey right now they have a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
the Google Chrome Store not using honey
that would be literally passing up free
money it is free to use it installs in
just a few seconds it's backed by PayPal
so you know that it's good get honey for
free at join honey calm slash Ben that
is join honey calm slash Ben go check
them out right now join honey calm slash
Ben so as I say the economic certainty
of loss is now quite real okay and the
possibility of mass death it's still out
there but we don't know exactly how high
it is this why I've said over the next
two weeks what we need from the federal
government is a metric we need some sort
of formula right we don't know what the
numbers are gonna be for a number of
death versus a number of cases we don't
know any of that stuff yet but we need a
formula for when the number of deaths
over the number of cases hits a certain
rate then step a kicks in and some of us
go back to work and if that number
declines further in terms of death rate
and number of cases then step B more of
us go back to work like we need a plan
at this point to get out of this because
this is utterly unsustainable and
because this is quickly turning into a
political fight where some people are
arguing that this is temporary and we
need to do what we can to hold up the
economy so that we can get back to work
and other people are arguing we need to
make this permanent and this is where
crap gets seriously ugly okay what we
are in right now is global pens it's
unprecedented in history of Western in
the history of modern economics this is
unprecedented a forcible global economic
shutdown never happened before and some
people are using this as an opportunity
they're using it as an opportunity to
talk about the permanent growth of
American governments and that is
disgusting okay if you have turned this
into your case for permanently growing
the size and state of American
government not for getting through the
crisis and going back to you know the
greatest functional economy in the
history of the world that is because
you're being a political hack and that
is what we are watching right now in
real time and that's like I don't want
to get political about this but I'm not
the one who made it political I thought
we were all on the same page when the
house is on fire you put out the fire
but well and when you got coronavirus
and maybe you need the hydro
hydroxychloroquine but there are some
people who insist that it's not
sufficient for us to take the
hydroxychloroquine and the azithromycin
and zinc
there are some people who are insistent
that we down the fish tank cleaner right
that we that you take the
hydroxychloroquine now but we need to
make that permanent from now on you're
gonna have to down a little bit of fish
tank cleaner every day and destroy the
American economy forever okay that is
that is the direction that I'm seeing
some people push when they talk about
endless spending little but endless
unemployment benefits when they pretend
that dealing with a crisis is the exact
same thing as dealing with a non crisis
and that the goal of this thing isn't to
move us past what's going on right now
we all agree on this that Senate bill
last night it has 96 nothing okay there
is no disagreement then we need to do
something now to stop complete economic
meltdown the question is how many people
out there are saying well now's the
opportunity for us to completely shift
our way of life because no crisis can go
to waste so how bad is the economic
downturn here
I mean it's horrific the economic
downturn is unprecedented as I say in
American history and in human history
we're looking at a 30 percent decline in
GDP in one quarter okay that's it that's
not obviously we have seen the local
percentages of businesses open has
dropped by forty three percent across
America the percentage of hourly
employees working has dropped by 55
percent across America so when people
say by the way that we're just doing
this that when you talk about reopening
the markets it's to save the Dow Jones
Industrial Average I promise you Warren
Buffett's still making money
Jeff Bezos doing ok people who are still
wealthy guess what they're still wealthy
they didn't sell their stock they're
still wealthy you know he's getting
absolutely shellacked by this by this
forcible economic downturn every small
business owner people who are operating
on thin margins every hourly employee of
those businesses what do you think is
happening to all the waiters what do you
thing to all the clerks right now what
do you think is happening to all the
people who staff up all the local small
businesses that you cannot go to anymore
so when we say that you how dare you
weigh all of the factors in determining
public policy why are you leaving those
people out to dry why are you pretending
that those people's livelihoods and
lives are completely are completely a
non-factor
and how you determine public policy here
I mean obviously this stuff does does
matter and it should matter I mean that
a huge percentage of us small businesses
are gonna run out of cash soon which is
why this was so necessary that's why it
passed 96 nothing the Senate bill in the
over 20% of American businesses had
enough cash to last a month less than a
month
between one and three months almost 35%
of American businesses so half of over
half of us small businesses say they
would completely die within three months
if sales stops completely which is
exactly what is happening almost no
businesses can last up to a year without
dying without running out of cash if
they don't get a shot in the arm soon
and you're seeing this with us home
sales its bottom line here is that the
economic realities are in fact realities
and that's something that we have to
take into account and we have to take
that into account along with all of the
new data that's being brought in from
the UK again I have yet to hear anybody
in the federal or state government
explain when do we have enough ICU beds
that that's enough and the answer is
they maybe they don't know we're gonna
know in the next week or two and to
pretend that we can't make those
calculations or start to make those
calculations is absolutely foolhardy
also in at least a piece of good news
warm human weather could slow the
coronavirus according to new research
says the end of Friedman and Simon
tenure reporting over at The Washington
Post
apparently the research on how the
corona virus behaves in various
temperatures and humidity levels is
demonstrating that upcoming changes of
the seasons may actually slow this thing
multiple early studies provide evidence
of statistical ties between temperature
and humidity ranges and the geographic
regions where the virus has thrived by
the way if this thing dies over the
summer even if we're hit with it
cyclically that would give us enough
months to build up the ICU and
ventilator capacity to handle it by you
at hope September October right that
would be the goal right Anthony foutch
II of the of the National Institute of
allergies and infectious diseases he was
out there saying this thing could be
cyclical right we could be hit with a
wave now and then it could die off
during the summer and then it could hit
again but the cyclical nature of the
thing means that you could send a lot of
people back to work and in the meantime
get your ass in gear and produce the
masks and the ventilators and the beds
that we need here's Anthony Falchi
yesterday saying this thing could in
fact be cyclical would this possibly
become a seasonal cyclic thing and I've
always indicated to you that I think it
very well might and the reason I say
that is that what we're starting to see
now in the southern hemisphere in
southern Africa and in the southern
hemisphere countries is that we're
having cases that are appearing as they
go into their winter season and if
in fact they have a substantial outbreak
it will be inevitable that we need to be
prepared that will get a cycle around
the second time okay but that gives us
sometimes actually build up the
resources plus we're gonna know in
fairly short order I think how many
people have already had this thing and
then we'll actually have some real data
there microbiology labs that are already
developing tests to detect if somebody
has already been hit with corona virus
and is thus immune and can return to
work meanwhile deborah birx who's
heading up the president's efforts on
corona virus headed up the the AIDS
effort by the US government years ago
she says the media are absolutely
frightening people with salacious
numbers but the numbers they're putting
out the studies they're putting out
number of people dead it's not going to
look anything like that here's dr. Deb
Roberts again not president Trump dr.
Deb Roberts making this point yesterday
the numbers that have been put out there
are actually very frightening to people
but I can tell you if you go back and
look at Wuhan and who Bay and all of
these provinces when they talk about
60,000 people being infected even if you
said oh right well there's asymptomatic
sand all of that so you get to 600,000
people out of 80 million that is nowhere
close to the numbers that you see people
putting out there I think it is
frightened the American people I think
on a freely and a model that you just
run full out you can get to those
numbers if you have zero controls and
you do nothing and we know that every
American is doing something okay so that
all of that is true and again the models
that have been used and the ones that
been put out by the media the ones
scared the living crap out of everybody
those models like at Imperial College
well that was the one went viral not the
Oxford University model that said that
this thing was gonna peter out fairly
quickly and then it was an order of
magnitude less deadly than we have
originally been told the imperial
college model is totally wrong the
british epidemiologist I told talked
about this a moment ago that British
epidemiologist has admitted it was
totally wrong UK will have enough beds
it's down the order of 20,000 dead in
the UK not 200,000 not 2,000,000 okay
that is a major screw-up like a serious
serious screw-up now does that mean it's
time to get out there and go out
partying no it does not mean that it
does mean that as the data comes in we
are gonna have to consider how we get
this thing back on the rails and that is
it is of priority
distress that balloons too near one
trillion dollars near the 2008 peak
according Bloomberg the amount of
distressed debt in the United States has
quadrupled in less than a week reaching
levels not seen since 2008 as the
collapse of oil prices in the fallout
from coronavirus shudders entire
industries across the globe
the total is probably even higher the
calculation does not include the debt of
small to medium-sized companies whose
loans trade rarely if at all this is
cause the worst sell-off since the
global financial crisis and deepens
stress in credit markets okay so
obviously all of this is a huge problem
Steve minuchin the Treasury secretary
says that the United States is going to
take stakes in Airlines in exchange for
grants that in order to bail out the
airlines basically they are going to
they are going to take a government
share of the airline so it looks a lot
like the auto bailout of 2008 but the
the Senate has now approved the larger
spending package in the history of the
United States the Senate bill has now
been approved 96 to nothing it sits with
Nancy Pelosi now who has been holding it
up because she's awful in every possible
way and this thing like I don't know
what her leverage is every single
Democrat voted in favor of this bill
Stinney Hoyer says that the house will
consider the stimulus bill as a Friday I
can't imagine that it will be held up
anymore it should be passed before the
weekend so what exactly is in this thing
according to The Wall Street Journal 250
billion dollars to make unemployment
insurance available to more categories
of workers and to extend the duration of
benefits to 39 weeks from 26 weeks
typical in most states it would also
provide an extra $600 a week for four
months
301 billion dollars in direct payments
to households 349 billion dollars and
loans to small businesses with the
amount spent on payroll rent or
utilities converting into grants that
don't have to be repaid 500 billion
dollars for loans loan guarantees or
other aid to businesses states and
municipalities including the possibility
that the gumpa the company the
government will take direct action
distressed companies that by the way
companies are going to reject this
our companies are just going to not do
it Boeing already said if you try to
take a stake in us we just won't take
the loan and so the government
absolutely caved and the Congress just
created an exception for Boeing they
said they were a national security
institution thirty two billion dollars
in grants to cover wages of passenger
air carriers cargo air carriers
contractors 150 billion dollars in
direct aid to States 221 billion dollars
in tax benefits for businesses 340
billion dollars in supplemental spending
by the way all sorts of money for like
public transit which
like I don't know why that's necessary
also just a bunch of like a bunch of
pork is in there like the Kennedy Center
got tens of millions of dollars there
the National Endowment for the Arts got
tens of millions of dollars the
corporation's public broadcasting got
tens of millions of dollars its it
listen on any normal level this Bill's a
bunch of crap I mean under any normal
level it's a bad bill but given the fact
that the alternative is either a pork
Laden bleep show or nothing and this is
going to allow businesses to continue to
operate for the next three months okay
but here's the problem when Lindsey
Graham makes this point right senator
from South Carolina he had held this up
last night because one of the provisions
of the bill that needed to be clarified
is it seemed from the bill that you
would actually get more money from being
on unemployment insurance than from
being employed which would create an
incentive for employers to throw people
out of work and throw them to the
unemployment lines I mean that that was
in the bill and so a few senators Ben
Sasse among them several senators last
night Lindsey Graham they'd said we need
to get that corrected they did get that
corrected and so the bill passed Lindsey
Graham said listen I don't love
everything in this bill but we need to
do something so here is Graham saying I
can tolerate some bad to do some good
here because we have no choice
there's a lot of good in this bill I'm
going to vote for it there medical
supplies that nurses and doctors and
hospitals need minuchin done a good job
very much trying to keep the democrats
from putting the green New Deal into the
bill but here's what we've done in the
name of doing good we're going to make
it hard for the next four months for
employers to find workers and we're
going to incentivize people to leave the
workforce because the first time in my
lifetime America will pay you more not
to work than work I can tolerate some
bad to do some good I made deals I know
what it's like to negotiate with the
other side but really do we need to be
giving PBS more money now when people
are dying of course none of that is
necessary we shouldn't have to do any of
this stuff but here's the point this is
not going to stop now is when the real
political battle begins right now you
got unanimous support to do something to
shore up the economy because the
government has forcibly driven a car
through your living room but there's an
entire side of the political aisle that
not only wants to make a lot of this
crap permanent but wants to expand on
this crap and you could see this break
out into the open over specifically the
provision that Graham is talking about
there was a provision in the
that basically suggested that you should
get $600 plus whatever salary you were
making your company in order to be
unemployed and Graham was like no that
doesn't make any sense if you're trying
to maintain jobs then what you don't do
is pay people more to stay out of work
then to stay in work that doesn't make
any sense enough people are gonna be
fired already
without incentivizing people to be
thrown off the payroll instead you have
Nancy Pelosi out there saying no no
we're talking about $600 what what do
you care what do you care we're spending
a lot of money anyway why not
incentivize people to be thrown out of
work this from the same lady who just a
few years ago was suggesting openly that
we need to make a national health
insurance system something akin to a
national health insurance system so that
people don't have a job lock right so
that they are not stuck in their jobs in
order to gain health insurance so Nancy
Pelosi has long been on board with the
idea of paying people to be unemployed
here's Nancy Pelosi talking about all of
this the fact is is that there is an
imbalance in our country an income
earner and therefore the unemployment
benefits but Lisa described it very well
it's complicated but it's complicated to
make it calibrate for every state so
just call it six hundred dollars around
the country and behind when the the fact
is is that we are a consumer economy and
that we really need people put money in
people's pockets so they can then expand
and jack demand into the economy grow
the economy and that's a good thing
okay first of all everything she's
saying there is crap about how this
economy is going to recover it's not
gonna recover because you just put money
in people's pockets
you think anyone right now is spending
extra money you think people are going
out and buying they're not where are
they gonna shop okay it's not a real
thing until the coronavirus thing is
solved I mean that this is basically
along the same way it's the Democratic
version of what if we gave a tax cut to
everybody and then they wouldn't spent
the money like I'm all in favor of tax
cuts but that ain't going to inject a
man into this economy that is not a
thing that's going to happen right now
there is no demand because nothing's
open because the government shut
everything down
and yet Bernie Sanders doing the same
routine bunny instead talking about how
how could the Republicans be so upset
about expanding unemployment benefits
beyond what they wanted originally it's
a very good thing
we should have permanent unemployment
okay first of all good rule of thumb is
Bernie's four it's a bunch of garbage
second thing the point here is not that
Republicans weren't expanding
unemployment was their proposal to do so
over the weekend the point is how long
is that going to last and incentivize
people to stay out of the work
artificially on the basis of debts that
we cannot even float at this point
because no other country has the
capacity to buy our debt but here's
Bernie Sanders grandstanding and being
rewarded for it on Twitter Twitter by
the way is the dumbest place on earth
I've spent less and less time on Twitter
over time there's a reason for that it
is because it is a repository of idiocy
and malice and just ridiculous garbage
anyway here is Bernie Sanders who again
was trending on Twitter Thank You bunny
for suggesting that people are greedy
for not trying to float unemployment
benefits 7 months out at the at the
employment wages that they are earning
earning right now now I find that some
of my Republican colleagues are very
distressed they're very upset but
somebody who's making 10 12 bucks an
hour might end up with a paycheck
for 4 months more than they received
last week oh my god the universe is
collapsing imagine that somebody was
making 12 bucks an hour now like the
rest of us faces an unprecedented
economic crisis with the 600 bucks on
top of their normal their regular
unemployment check might be making a few
bucks more for four months oh my word
will the universe survive okay
no the point here is that when you
incentivize millions of people to stay
out of the workforce after the crisis
remember after the crisis and this has
been my point here my point is not that
we shouldn't have done something we
should have done something my point is
what you do should be geared towards
solving the crisis okay it should not
take the hydroxychloroquine for the for
the for the proscribed coronavirus take
take the amount don't drink the fish
tank cleaner Bernie wants you to drink
the fish tank cleaner economically ok
the Democrats want to drink the fish
tank cleaner economically this is what
they want they want neverending spending
they're trying to make this all
permanent I'm gonna get to into more of
this in just one second I'm gonna
demonstrate to you that now this has
become political it started off as a
political it should remain a political
it is no longer in political nor will it
be a political in the upcoming weeks as
the economy remains closed and that's
ugly we need to be talking about how we
get enough ICU beds enough ventilators
enough resources mobilize that we can
all go back to work as soon as possible
instead we're gonna get debates over a
fourth round of stimulus a fifth round
of stimulus
based on money that doesn't exist based
on debt that we cannot sell based on
economic economies around the world that
are not working we'll get into more of
this in just one second first if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content called all-access live you
should head on over to daily wire dicom
and check it out Jeremy boring and I
kicked it off last week it is massively
popular people are loving it we're gonna
continue all this week at 8 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific Basin informal hangout
well one of our hosts sits down with you
and we just hang we just we just chatted
up and have a party and I played random
music for you and answer your questions
or Jeremy talks about religion or
Michael just Jabir's about I have no
idea about what like cigars and smoking
jackets or something the show's intended
for our all-access members but during
this national emergency this time of
isolation we know that everybody just
needs to hang out and chill out so party
with us over at daily wired , all-access
live show if you're around at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 him pacific tonight join
andrew Clavin on the all-access live
show and have a congenial convivial time
with our friend andrew Clavin again this
is for all of our members so go get a
membership right now over at daly
wire.com we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay this is the largest spending bubble
in the history of the United States and
Democrat after Democratic for Democrat
for Democrat is saying we need more we
need more okay now listen if you can
make the case why the more is going to
shore up the businesses that are gonna
die love to hear it but if this is just
you prioritizing your garbage priorities
that you couldn't get past in a normal
time and you're doing it under cover of
night in order to take advantage of a
crisis that's you being a crap person
it's a bad crisis and so your immediate
responses but what if we could get a
green new deal what if we could do that
and it's a universal call from the
Democrats shocka shocka shocka Kirsten
Gillibrand senator from New York says we
need to spend more we literally just
spent two trillion dollars the entire
normal budget of the United States in a
in a year in which we'll run one
trillion dollar deficit is four trillion
dollars we just took that and multiplied
it by half added it to the budget for a
basically a two to three month period
that's what we're talking about here we
all hope and pray and in all likelihood
it will be two to three months we had on
yesterday dr. Marty Mike Harry from
Johns Hopkins University he says this
thing is gonna wane by May okay so for
two to three months we're talking about
this fine okay but you're talking about
making it permanent we need to spend
more and more and more more why it's
almost as though you're attempting to
confirm your political priors by
referring to a crisis that should be
temporary and that we should we should
be looking to get out of not to
exacerbate here's Christian Gillibrand
we need to spend more this bill is very
helpful but it's just the first step
this is going to be a very long-term
crisis it's going to take months and
months to get out of it and frankly I
don't think our economy is going to
return to where it was for a long time
more than months perhaps years and so
the truth is our job is to do triage
right now we needed to get real dollars
into hands of real people this is not
intended to make all states whole it
couldn't possibly do that but it's
intended to get us through the next four
weeks and hopefully the next four months
in terms of the coverage of employees
the easiest thing to do as a politician
by the way is to shout that you need
more money always to shout that you need
more money the question is how do you
draw the balance between what we
actually need right now and running up
that credit card forever because guess
what you wanted to press the economy you
want to ensure that we actually
can't do any of the things that we need
to do as an economy want to raise taxes
dramatically because here's here's the
reality at a certain point here we're
gonna have to pay back these bonds at a
certain point here you're gonna have to
raise taxes in order to pay for this
stuff and sink the economy in the
process so you are taking a short term
hit right now but turning it into a long
term had a permanent hit forever two
trillion dollars of spending right now
and in watching Democrats immediately
claim that they need to spend like 30
trillion bucks
because of the two trillion right Joe
Biden who's barely a sentient human
being at this point I'm not sure that
he's alive Joe Biden yesterday he said
well in the next in the next round of
negotiations and roll kosnov Court has
his green new deal was set to cost what
was it it was some like 90 trillion
dollars over the course the next thirty
years or something something insane it's
something completely crazy and Joe
Biden's like well maybe we'll do a green
really is everybody begging for solar
panels right now last I checked
everybody's wants to go back to work
everybody just wants to be healthy and
go back to work those would be the two
priorities and Joe Biden's like what if
we could have a windmill
like a wooden mill you know like when I
was a boy back in the 1930s and I used
to have to have one of those little
there's a little you know like they're
not windmill but like Oh like one of
those thing you blow on it it spins it
spins like really pretty like a
kaleidoscope go Joe Biden we're gonna
have an opportunity I believe in the
next round here to use the my green
economy my Green Deal or to be able to
generate both economic growth and
consistent with the kind of infusion of
monies we need into the system to keep
it going one of the ways to make sure
these jobs are available that may get
lost or hurt in the meantime is to
provide the kind of jobs that are
prevailing wages where people are making
forty five fifty dollars an hour plus
benefits by building new infrastructure
remember that time that the Obama
administration tried this with shovel
ready jobs and then created zero jobs
remember that remember that time they
tried this with green jobs remember they
did green jobs aren't in Van Jones
remember they created no jobs Van Jones
admitted they could not actually peg
down one green new job that had been
created remember that so now Joe Biden's
doing the same thing on the back of this
but Joe Biden isn't onions oh you know
maybe we'll do like you know maybe like
um student loan forgiveness like a
general manager to help the folks
this bill leaves out including young
people this bill doesn't include student
loan forgiveness which would go a long
way to provide an immediate relief for
those who need it the most
I support forgiving at least $10,000 in
student loan debt per person now it
doesn't include the cost free treatment
for the Cova 19 what what whatever the
costs are relating to that this should
be cost free okay guys when I say this
is gonna turn into a political battle
this is what I mean and this is why I've
said before you know there are a lot of
things that I'm not fond of about
President Trump one thing I'm fond of is
the man does not want to destroy the
American economy on the basis of a
crisis if the Democrat were president
right now they'd be nationalizing
everything in sight the orden a tional
eyes the health supply industry they
already would have been pushing for a
green new deal they didn't pushing for
permanent federal jobs that's what
they're doing over at salon.com by the
way or slate rather there's an entire
piece of slate called the Senate
coronavirus bill is not going to be
enough by Daniel carpenter what is he
suggesting well aside from hiring up
some federal workers for the CDC and the
FDA which is totally fine and hiring up
some new people at the unemployment
office he wants there to be permanent
hiring in the transport infrastructure
industry what the hell does that have to
do with anything he wants a permanent
hiring in the alternative energy
infrastructure Department this is
planning and rollout from more expansive
grid of electric cars solar panels and
wind farms necessitates hiring workers
what the hell does that have to with
coronavirus what are you even talking
about he says if the economic and health
reasons for stimulus through public
sector hiring are not enough consider
two other benefits of government hiring
first an infrastructure plan that relies
largely or entirely on contractors will
likely exacerbate the social and
economic inequality that have torn our
country apart government jobs ride solid
benefits oh so it's like your why it's
almost as though you're looking for a
government jobs program like Bernie
Sanders wanted in the first place and
you're using a crisis in order to try
and guarantee that it you got that
listen you got all of us on board
because we had to some of us are not
super happy about a two trillion dollar
spending plan we wonder whether that two
trillion dollars is actually what is
fully necessary or whether 1.5 trillion
dollars would have done it or whether
they should have been zero interest
loans rather than grants or whether they
should been funneled through the banks
that were already guaranteeing the loans
and you
unemployment insurance on the other side
for the people who legit are thrown out
of jobs
maybe some of us think there was a
better way to do this yield but knowing
what was going on
is y'all had to be done fine and now
your immediate claim is that we have not
done enough and that we need to spend
more money you need to spend more most
as though this is a political a
political agenda driven nonsensical
thing that you guys are pushing here and
it has nothing to do with reality almost
as though almost as though it's time for
some things I like and some things that
I hate so let's do some things I like in
some things that I hate so you know what
we will skip things that I like today
let's do so a thing I hate instead okay
so the the intrepid reporter Mark Fisher
Washington Post senior editor the author
of Trump revealed he has a a tweet today
here's the tweet Scot McMillan a 56 year
old lawyer tweeted that it's more vital
to revive the economy than to save
people who are not productive like the
elderly and infirm so I called his
parents okay so um he's a lawyer he
expressed a public policy position that
is really unpopular and in my opinion
wrong and you called his mommy like this
is absolute journalism in of highest
quality a Rando said a thing you don't
like so you called his mommy as a
reporter for the Washington Post
Wow our journalistic site rust them so
much I trust those UK experts who
revised their initial estimate down from
500 10,000 deaths to 20,000 deaths over
the course of one week and their
estimate for coronavirus is spread from
12 months to two weeks I'm like the peak
is gonna happen I trust all experts I
trust them so much I trust them so much
and I trust our journalistic experts to
bring us nothing but truth I trust the
what democracy dies in darkness guys
here this is what the article says he
urged saving the economy over protecting
those who are quote not productive from
the coronavirus then he faced America's
wrath Scot McMillan had had it with
being cooped up with the whole country
being closed but the collapsing market
in the isolation the constant worry the
politicians who didn't take coronavirus
seriously when they could have on Sunday
night McMillan a 56 year old lawyer in
La Mesa California near San Diego saw a
president from sweet about how we cannot
let the Cure be worse than the
itself the lawyer took to Twitter to add
his own two sons he tweeted the
fundamental problem is whether we're
gonna tank the entire economy to save
2.5 percent of the population which is
one generally expensive to maintain and
2 not productive ok well that is a very
poor way of putting this thing because
number one all we don't want any of
those old people to die and number two
he's he's expressing basically that you
have to take everything into
consideration but in a very gauche way I
mean that would that be the best way to
describe what he is doing and he's
saying that obviously every public
policies balance it's the same thing
that happened with lieutenant governor
of Texas and Patrick people are
expressing he needs to balance
priorities in the dumbest possible way
but the overall point which is that
obviously public policy takes into
account both the risk to human life and
the risk to economics which again is
real life for millions and millions of
people who are waking up without a job
today right that that is a that is a
thing that we have to take into account
now he puts that in a gauche way and so
the Washington Post called his mommy
seriously people called him a liberal
and white right wing nut even a Nazi
they threatened his livelihood his
family his home polite people told him
about their elderly parents who teach
their grandchildren Latin and music and
produced more happiness in their golden
years than most working people do in
their entire careers the mean people who
are not shy on Twitter invoked a full
array of lawyer jokes Soylent Green in
the Holocaust to convey just how awful
Macmillan was for applying that old or
infirm people should be put aside to
allow America to get back to work
Macmillan told The Washington Post I'm
not a cold-hearted monster nature does
this every so often it wipes out a bunch
of us Macmillan was not the first person
to express the idea it's more important
for the country to get back to work
than it is to do everything possible to
protect the elderly and the infirm and
the anxious political and personal
struggle between doing whatever it takes
to avoid a wicked sometimes lethal virus
and doing what is needed to revive a
suddenly dormant economy macmillan sweet
became a lightning rod so Washington
Post immediately jumped into the story
and instead of saying this is a random
dude on Twitter who said a dumb thing
instead the Washington Post decided you
know what be great we will call his
mummy or cuz mommy as the blueblack grew
fierce the Boyar took down his own
tweets took down his website screened
his calls he was miserable
he took his chloroquine the anti malaria
drug Trump kept talking up hoping it
might protect him against the virus
though there is no evidence it will it
makes him feel like crap
he lured his dose but keeps taking it
because he said maybe it does work okay
so this guy's kind of nutty anyway right
he doesn't have coronavirus and he's
taking chloroquine and so you picked on
a guy
who seems like he is semi nutty and he
called his parents he remained
unapologetic on Twitter he wrote that
his approach whether you like it or not
is the analysis that will be performed
by our political leaders in our medical
personnel look look at Italy he said I
don't want to take out the old people I
don't want the kids coming up today to
be akin to the depression kids the
longer this drags on without people
working the worse it's gonna be
we can't allow our society to collapse
over this so here is what the Washington
Post did in their quest for democracy
not dying in darkness Scott's father Jim
McMillian is alive he's 78 Scott's
mother Gloria is 75 there well they are
by Scott's measure not productive
Jim's retired lawyer glories a retired
high school English teacher they've been
especially not productive since February
23rd which is the last time they left
their house in San Diego when they went
to the LA opera to watch a performance
of your DJ well well the last time
except for 10 days ago when Jim said he
was going to the Home Depot to get a
light switch to replace the one that
went on the fritz he said he went out
not bothering if gloves or masks and
then he stopped by Walmart to look at
canned goods he bought some coolant and
his wife yelled at him since the Walmart
trip they've continued their not
productive life at home the main
activity is watching News says Gloria
Jim in glory I like to argue about the
virus the president pretty much anything
they argue about whether they arguing
about who wins they agree with their son
Scott that trump tallied too long and
failed to act they agree with their son
Scott the president is right to push now
to restart the economy and they agree
with Scott that businesses should reopen
even if it means putting old folks in
people with underlying illnesses and
other non-productive
types into quarantine for an extended
period so I guess that they called his
parents his parents like okay how the
hell is that a story okay so not only is
it not us to worry about the guy said on
Twitter it is also not a story when you
call his mommy and daddy and it is super
not a story when they're like yeah fine
whatever that's called not a story The
Washington Post devoted several thousand
words to this several thousand words to
this nonsense is well done well done
Washington Post our journalistic betters
in for keeping us informed every single
day
incredible alrighty we'll be back here
later to do two additional hours of
content hopefully some more good news
for you otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow make sure to check out our
all-access lab by going to daily wire
calm and relieve ins on tonight hanging
out with you I'll be back a little bit
later this week ending tomorrow hanging
out with you
so go join up a daily where I can't
become part of our community you're
listening to the bench
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick sheep an associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Rowe Romina hair
and makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Clavin show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]